okay so I guess it just goes to show
that sometimes the earlybird not only
gets the worm it also gets a jetski see
you next time on every damn day cut fine
work everyone Brian your body wears
clothes from remember everyone's scripts
are due by 2:00 p.m. today get it done
everyone no distractions don't you guys
like working finally our old tears are
our old chairs are perfectly fine let's
not get distracted yeah so sturdy
something and it's whistles like a
goddamn champ oh my god okay we've been
talking and I think it likes me
permission to marry the chair know if
anybody should get to marry the chair it
should be me I too AM sturdy and
reliable I have a family one girlfriend
one dog it's just a chair doesn't have
feelings
Thank You Hannah that being said either
I get the chair or give it a UTI no
don't rub your gross parts on the chair
Stuart I'm taking the chair
Oh Oh did someone in this chair who
in this chair me all of you in
this chair when earlier in the sketch
just know I'm literally always I
can't stop eating lactose how did this
escalate this so quickly and
why do you all still want a chair that
everyone has sat in on everyone I in
shin this chair but I'm gonna in
this chair I'm gonna all over your
Jordan by on Jordan
yeah all of you want the chair then all
of you get the chair I'm gonna cut the
chair up into five little pieces every
piece will have on it is that what
you wanted yes yes yes
[Music]
yeah I think they delivered my chair to
your office by mistake oh there it is I
see you got started on the
chair before me well
[Music]
you